natalie met her producer at our birthday
show
yeah that's right jack antonoff uh great
producer of uh music
yeah so our tables were near each other
he was there with lena yeah
uh-huh yep he was his studio that he was
recording at a lot was right around the
corner from my apartment that i used to
have there
and he just asked do you want to come
over tomorrow and
try to write i just loved watching him
work how he we'd never written like that
building a track as you're
writing the lyrics and the melody and
it's such a better way of writing for me
i don't think i could ever go back to
like sitting around a guitar and writing
a song it's so much easier when you
have um a groove and sort of a track and
a beat being built because it just
makes you hear a lot more ideas of
how phrasing can go and how much more
percussive lyrics could be this would be
inhibiting to me
in a songwriting process if i'm sitting
there with somebody else and he comes up
with a drum beat and all of a sudden i
started to kind of
try to find lyrics i imagine at first
they sound
ridiculous well with the three of us
we're so comfortable with each other
we'll just be like no no uh but what
about this like even if you don't
necessarily love somebody's idea there's
probably one thing that you grab on to
and take it to the next
place but you know we thought we were
going to record this record
like the pop hip-hop way where there's a
different producer
on every song then when we started
riding with jack it just felt so
comfortable and it was really hard going
into writing sessions
with new people all the time and like
going okay
so you don't know me but here's what's
going on in my life and what i want to
write about
it was uh it was a lot so jack is
one of those people yeah he's like a
brother you just feel so comfortable
right away
he was making fun of us we were making
fun of him you could totally say no no
no we're not doing that that's
crappy uh a funny thing about jack every
time jack is just sort of ad-libbing
lyrics
because it's about the melody it's
always about like fire and burning it up
and tearing it down and it's on fire and
we're like what's your thing with fire
you really
you got you got something motivated